On May 18, 2021, Ziggo, the largest Dutch cable operator, announced to the world that it would no
longer control the rights for broadcasting Formula 1 in the Netherlands.
What immediately followed was not much, because who actually spends time looking at Ziggo’s Twitter feed?
But after Dutch Formula 1 fans realized that this would mean signing up for the streaming service Viaplay
for the very unacceptable Dutch price of 14 euros per month, fans would begin to start getting angry.
What made this change more notable, however, was that the Dutch weren’t alone.
Only a year before, Nordic Entertainment Group, the owner of Viaplay, also secured a deal that acquired them continued,
exclusive rights for Formula 1 in every single Nordic country from 2022 to 2024.
This was followed by an expansion into the Baltics, pivoting off of ice hockey,
as well as acquiring exclusive rights for Formula 1 in Poland.
Their intentions? Clear.
Europe is not known for its streaming services.
To no surprise, American media remains dominant everywhere.
And as the amount of streaming subscriptions increases in Europe,
Europeans continue to consume mainly American licensed content.
A question to ask is if you’re a European company that wants to become a streaming giant
that could compete on the European market, how could you do it?
You could maybe tried to take a bet on an entirely new medium for mass consumption
and rely on a base of consumers that are eccentric enough to get DVDs delivered through mail.
You could rely on decentralized content loaded with ads submitted by users with no social life
and an inability to tell their parents they’re doing something meaningful with their lives.
You could rely on your globally successful brands and people's nostalgia.
But you could also, of course, just be Jeff Bezos.
What makes Nordic Entertainment Group, the leader of the pack when it comes to European streaming companies,
is that it has a combination of strategies that no other European media company has been able to fully replicate.
They invested in streaming services when it wasn’t financially feasible to do it;
they rely, and still do, on a bed of nostalgic Nordic content,
people across the world love
to act like they consume;
and probably the most important thing is that they did something Netflix hasn’t:
"...so Netflix is directly going after your territory, it's opening up an office
in the Nordics later this year in Stockholm
it's saying by the end of the year it'll have nearly 70 original titles coming from the Nordics,
so it is going after your space whether you're from the same background or not.
How will youcompete with someone now with such a deep wallet, such a deep pocket as Netflix when it's making
original content like this?
Anders Jensen (Nent CEO): "Well the originalcontent that you refer, it has taken time to build up,
we have 129 original titles on our platformnow when we're stepping up and we're moving into producing content in other territories as well.
What we do have that Netflix doesn't have and I do think that the different sort of backgroundsmatter,
is that we have a long history of producing world-class sport productions.
We've movedthat over to streaming and we produce more than 50 000 live hours of sports and that's a verydifferent platform experience.
That allows us to move into new territories in a differentway where Netflix and other globals don't compete."
Sports are a form of entertainment that hashistorically been sticky and remained a domainof linear TV.
Live sports rights are not cheap after all, and a lot of exclusive sports streaming deals
operate at a loss while mainly being used for advertising the larger streaming service.
Live-streaming sports is difficult to do, and rewatching sports would not be
as common as doing the same for popular TV shows.
This is why some companies will package sports into documentary style content
that can stay relevant – profitable – for longer periods of time.
It's this investment into sports content, even though it would seem like would only
produce losses, that separates Nordic Entertainment Group.
They’ve taken a bet on inelastic demand:
dedicated Formula 1 watchers will go to where Formula 1 is being shown,  even if it means paying a higher price,
and Nordic Entertainment Group will
then try to keep them with original content
that they hope will be more profitable in eachrespective country:
Dutch viewers will now be given their own Viaplay original version of Dragon’s den (alongside others),
Polish viewers 'Polish Murderesses,' and Estonians to ‘Who Shot Otto Mueller.’
Max Verstappen also announced, along with his father, a multi-year content partnership with Viaplay
to produce documentary style content even when he originally rejected working
with Drive to Survive because of its supposed sensationalism.
The reason for paying an insane amount to get Verstappen is simple:
With almost a cult like following, by acquiring him to produce exclusive content,
Nordic Entertainment Group can try to turn sceptical Formula 1 motivated,
potential Dutch subscribers into enthusiastic ones.
In 2018, EU officials slapped on a directive to try and encourage American streaming companies
to uphold some form of minimum European content.
However, EU directives are practically always legally obscure because it's encouragement by
the EU for each member state's own specific legislation
rather than a concrete requirement for what they have to do.
And either way, the directive may not even be that necessary.
As subscriber growth stalls in America, streaming services will then try and compete for international markets
by also producing original content in other countries
For Europhiles, this may seem like a good thing in itself.
But again, there are nuances.
where do the borders for what is European content begin and end?
The French have been advocating for an even larger percentage of, air quotes, “European Content,”
but people know France.
There is no other European country probably as culturally anxious about Anglo-Saxon content.
It’s part of the reason some Europeans see the “European” efforts by the French as merely a Trojan horse:
is the 60% French requirement of European content automatically the same as 60% European content,
or is it, merely, a means for boosting the French?
It leads to an interesting question: is content originating from Europe important in itself?
It’s a question I am not qualified to answer because I know nothing,
and I ironically have way too much of an American accent.
But it’s one you can try to by spending your valuable fleeting, conscious time getting angry on the Internet.